the devastating wildfires in Australia
have prompted one of the largest
evacuation in the country's history Navy
ships are helping hundreds of people
leave their neighborhoods more than
100,000 residents and tourists have been
forced to flee hundreds of fires have
burned roughly 12 million acres at least
19 people have died Natacha X will be of
our news partner Network 10 News is in
mallacoota good morning the navy vessel
is now four hours into what will be a
20-hour journey and the people on board
are fleeing one of the worst natural
disasters Australia has ever seen we now
have bush fires raging across more than
half of the country our Prime Minister
is facing his own political disaster
when he visited one of these communities
he was confronted by very angry
residents whose house has been moved
down this was recorded on camera and
those pictures have also gone right
around the world but here in Australia
we're still very much focused on the
natural disaster at hand we've been told
that the situation is going to intensify
in the next 24 hours
major Blazers are going to combine to
form one massive fire and everyone here
is on very high alert this is Natasha
Rex we'll be for CBS this morning
mallacoota Australia
you